So let's look at the sizes of
some actual virtual index,
physical intact caches.
While doing the previous quiz,
we have figured out that the cache
size needs to be less then or
equal to the associativity of
the cache times the page size.
So if we look at, for example,
the Intel Pentium 4 processor,
it has a four-way set associate
cache and a page size
of four kilobytes and
it's level one cache is 16 kilobytes.
The more recent Core 2,
Hehalem, Sandy Bridge, and
Haswell processors from Intel
are eight-way set associative.
Or course, they still have the four
kilobyte page size and surprise,
surprise, the level one
cache is 32 kilobytes.
The upcoming Skylake design from Intel
is rumored to be 16-way set associative
and you guessed it, it's rumored to
have a 64 kilobyte level one cache.